♪♪  ♪  ♪
- - Stéphanie Chouinard, Stéphae
GrGrammond et Christian Dufour.
BoBonsoir.
BoBon retour Christian, les gens
sese demandaient, avez-vous évié
ChChristian parce qu'ils ne
pepensent pas comme les autres?
MaMais vous étiez en vacances.
- - Oui, je vous aime beaucoup t
jeje sais que vous m'aimez
bebeaucoup.
- - Assouplissement rythme
vavariable au Canada. Je vous fs
enentendre Monsieur Dubé qui dit
ququi ne peut pas tout ouvrir tt
dede suite.
CHCHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre de la
SaSanté et des Services sociauxc
- - On a toujours suivi la santé
pupublique et la santé publique
vava regarder comment ça évolue.
EtEt s'ils recommandent
ququ'un moment donné, on n'a pls
bebesoin du passeport vaccinal,
onon va êtrtre heureux de le fa.
LaLa mêmeme chose pour les écols
etet les enfants. Il faut êtrtre
cacapable de tenir compte
dede la situation. Alors,
écécoutons la santé publique.
JuJusqu'à m maintenant, je pense
quque ça a été très s payant.
JAJASON KENNEY,
prpremier ministre de l'Alberta
- - Nous avons vu les tendances
sesemblables dans plusieurs pays
etet juridictions. C'est la rain
popour laquelle l'Angleterre,
l'l'Irlande, la Norvègege, la S,
lele Danemark et plusieurs autrs
papays, l'Afrique du Sud, c'est
lala raison pour laquelle
plplusieurs États aux États-Unis
onont décidé d'éliminter
prpresque toutes leueurs mesures
dede santé publique.
PIPIERRE POILIEVRE
cacandidat à l la chefferie, PCC
- - Alors lâchche pas!
LaLa liberté est en train
dede gagner. Mais il faut pas
ararrêteter non plus.
S Signez ma pétition!
- - Et on le voit. Il y a un peu
papartout des pressions pour
acaccélérer l'apaisement de tous
leles mesures sanitaires.
EÉvidemment Canada, les gens
c'c'est plus facile de se compar
àà c ce Canada que ça plus vite.
- - Oui très s certainement on u
plplusieurs premiers ministres
prprovinciaux avec des annoncese
dédéconfinement à g géométrie
vavariable. À certains endroitsn
sese débarrasse des passeport
vavaccinal.
- - C'est le passeport vaccinal
ququi devient le nouveau sujet.
C'C'est l'élément qu'on va
reregarder avec plus de soins. e
nene sais pas s'il avait entendu
leles commerçants mais certains
dedes éléments de laisser-aller.
QuQu'en pensez-vous?
- - Pour l'instant ça demeure un
ououtil utile. Il faut comprende
quque si on donne plus de terret
ququ'on dit aux gens: faites voe
prpropre arbitre de la situation
etet apprenez à v vivre avec le
vivirus, il faut aussi qu'il y t
dedes outils. Un des outils c'et
lala vaccination, la troisièmeme
dodose est important. On n'est s
sisi avancé que ça malheureusemt
QuQuébec. Il y a encore beaucoup
d'd'aînénés qui vivent à d domis
ququi n'ont pas encore, qui qui
n'n'ont pas leur troisièmeme dot
çaça ça pourrait assez
cacatastrophique. Le passeport
vavaccinal dans toute cette
éqéquation la demeure pour un
cecertain temps, peut-êtrtre pas
ététernellement une solution
avavantageuse. Pour protéger les
gegens qui vont recommencer
grgraduellement aller fréquenter
dadavantage de commerce.
- - Christian?
- - Moi j'ai toujours été contre
lele passeport vaccinal vous le
sasavais. Le lien entre le
papasseport vaccinal et la
prpropagation de la copine n'est
papas prouvée. Le Québec bat tos
leles records dans les mesures.n
n'n'est pas dans la science on t
dadans la politique et
l'l'idéologie. Moi je trouve ça
dédésolant. Je suis parti du
QuQuébec un long moment et j'ai
susuivi le drame qui est arrivéu
cocours de Noël. Parce que la
papandémie s'est mis à p prendre
totoute la place. C'est devenu
obobsessionnel. Un tas de gens a
didit: on écoute les nouvelles,n
esest plus capable c'est trop.
- - En mêmeme temps que dans les
momontait.
- - Oui je le sais tout ça moi e
nene suis pas un expert sanitai.
HiHier je suis arrivé à l l'aért
etet on est profondément enlisé.
OnOn est de plus un flux divisé.
OnOn est divisé entre ceux qui t
enencore peur de virus, il y a n
esespècece de traumatisme et aui
totous ceux qui en ont leur ras-
lele-bol, qui ne sont plus
cacapables moi je fais parti de
çaça. Je voyais les annonces de
MoMonsieur Legault, c'est bien
bebeau les programmes qui s'en
viviennent mais moi je me
dédébarrasserais tout de suite u
papasseport vaccinal. Le masque
auaussi. Je reviens de voyage de
sosociété où le masque est
rerecommandé mais pas obligé. Je
seservais morale et j'ai dit: w.
OnOn est plus enlisé qu'ailleur.
- - Les manifestations, qui
rerendent compte du ras-le-bol
dodont vous avez parlé, Monsieur
- - Alors qui est assez enlisé,
popour reprendre les mots de
ChChristian à O Ottawa. On nous
didisait que ce soir il y avait
dedes rumeurs que la police allt
memettre plus de pression sur ls
mamanifestants, le pont il ne pt
papas laisser ça ralentit trèss
lolongtemps.
- - Non c'est certainement un
enenjeu d'autant plus que le pot
esest l'une des plaques tournans
dede l'import-export avec les
EÉtats-Unis. C'est 70 % de touts
nonos exportations qui vont aux
EÉtats-Unis. Donc en termes de
PIPIB, la fermeture avec la
frfrontièrere de ce pays-là c ct
totout à f fait névralgique.e. n
cocommence à s sentir du pressiu
mimilieu du camionnage. On a des
cacamions avec des denrées
pépérissables sont bloqués depus
dedes jours mais aussi des milix
sysyndicaux. Il dépend de ce qui
sese passe de part et d'autre pr
alaller de l'avant. On sait qu'l
y a une pénurie c'est d'autant
plplus important mais d'autant
plplus d'un point de vue
écéconomique s'expose à O Ottaw.
- - Vous avez l'impression qu'on
vava agir plus vite la cave
OtOttawa?
- - Oui on peut pas se dire qu'à
OtOttawa on agite. Les policiers
dede Ottawa ont eu l'air
cocomplètetement dépassé. On net
papas dire que le premier minise
a a été si ferme, pas qu'il n'a
papas tenu la ligne dure mais
dedepuis deux semaines, on a
l'l'impression qu'il estst un pu
auaux abonnés absents. On a vu a
didifférence à Q Québec d'avoirs
élélus qui se sont mobilisés et
ququi ont dit non: ici vous ne
viviendrez pas jamais la capita.
CÇa commence fonctionner, vous
veverrez qu'ils ont eu le mémo s
avavaient vu ses qui s'est passà
OtOttawa. Ça va prendre plus de
ririgueur dans l'application de
totout ça. De là  à a appeler le
onon espèrere que ça se rendra s
llà. . Ces populations ne peut s
prprendre la population en otag.
EnEn faisant toutes sortes de
dedemandes notamment que le
prpremier ministre en mal, il a
totout de mêmeme été élu par 17
mimillions d'électeurs.
- - Christian, on a comprit vote
raras-le-bol, mais en mêmeme tes
blbloquer une ville, bloquer un
popont il y a des limites.
- - Il y a deux volets, il y a
vrvraiment une faillite de
leleadership au fédéral dans
l'l'observation. Ça c'est
ininacceptable. C'est la mêmeme
chchose qu'avec le dossier
auautochtone comme pendant deux
sesemaines déjà r respectées paa
loloi et on osait pas interveni.
CeCela dit, ce mouvement la
rereprésente quelque chose de
prprofond Canada. C'est bien por
lala bien pensante politique ou
mémédiatique, ça va aller trèss
fort au Canada mais le ras-le-
bobol de la population et
s's'explique aussi par ce
cacamionneur. Il y a un dérapage
mamanque de leadership.
- - Si vous me permettez, je
trtrouve ça étonnant que persone
nene parle de Doug Ford. Il n'et
papas allé à O Ottawa depuis le
dédébut de la manifestation à
OtOttawa. C'est comme ça provin.
CÇa demeure sa responsabilité. n
pepeut certainement blâmemer le
féfédéral de ne pas avoir réagi
asassez vite mais il manque de
leleadership aussi.
- - Comme c'est Ottawa et
inindustrie fédérale de
WaWashington. Joël Lightbound, a
didit je ne suis pas d'accord ac
lele temps qu'amplement premier
miministre. De vouloir marquer s
popoints politiques dans une joe
popolitique sur la vaccination.e
nene suis pas d'accord sur la
vavaccination obligatoire des
sosommes des employés fédéraux
ddînener camionneur. Donc on on
l'l'entendu hier. Aujourd'hui,
YvYves Robillard, dans le comtée
MaMarc-Aurèlele Fortin qui a die
susuis totalement d'accord avec
JoJoël. Cette idée qu'on en a
pepeut-êtrtre faite trop,
n'n'appartient pas uniquement ax
gegens d'extrêmeme droite.
- - Ça fait le tour du Canada, a
n'n'intéresse pas juste les
frfrancophones parce que c'est
prprofond. Il dit des choses qui
sosont très s très s vrai. Monsr
TrTrudeau a vraiment disait la
popopulation sur cet enjeu-là. n
sese retrouve dans une société i
esest profondément divisée parce
quque le ras-le-bol allait le
gagarder mesures sanitaires est
enencore très s fort. Une partie
lala population en vue ou non
vavaccinée, Monsieur Lightbound
chchapeau, ça fait du bien avoir
unun jeune politicien qui dit ce
quque moi je voulais entendre.
- - Ça commence à  êtrtre une fe
plplus importante au sein du
cacaucus libéral.
- - C'est quand mêmeme intéresst
paparce qu'on est plus habitué e
vovoir un déchirement qui s'en
prprend au parti conservateur ms
leles libéraux, tout ça se passe
enen famille. Habituellement. Ms
dedevant les fissures commence à
crcraquer, dans la peinture, c't
ququand mêmeme symptomatique pe-
êêtrtre d'une division à
l'l'intérieur mêmeme du pays et
c'c'est vrai on le voit, il y au
unun sondage Léger encore tout
rérécemment qui dit que il y a
prpratiquement le tiers de la
popopulation se dit quand mêmemn
acaccord par les propos qui sont
tetenus par les camionneur. C'et
ququand mêmeme significatif. Ese
quque ça va s'étioler au fur età
memesure que les inconvénients
vovont devenir plus grands pour
leles gens, du côtété des gentsi
sosont victimes des manifestant.
IlIl faut bien dire des mesures
sasanitaires, se relâchchent. À
QuQuébec, un peu partout, en
AlAlberta. Donc les manifestants
sosont un peu rattrapés par ce i
sese passe, par le relâchchemens
memesures. Puis avalez-moi leurs
rerevendications vont êtrtre
jujustifiées.
- - Je posais la question
cacamionneur français, vous
ararrivez un moment où on ouvre
leles sociétés en France
nonotamment.
- - Oui tout à f fait, et donc a
cocomporte un risque ce timing .
CÇa peut êtrtre interprété par s
chchefs d'occupation à O Ottawa
cocomme une victoire. On peut de
totoute la journée il est 3h30,n
vava avoir raison deux fois dans
lala journée. Avec la fin de
l'l'hiver, il y avait une des
bobonnes chances qu'on commença
rerelâchcher les mesures sanita.
- - Vous, Lightbound croyez-vous
ququ'il a un effet plus profond?
- - C'est étonnant qu'on voit ça
auau Canada comme coup d'éclat,a
popolitique au Canada est
exextrêmemement disciplinée si e
papassait en Grande-Bretagne, ce
seserait de la poutine
ququotidienne. Si on se dit je e
susuis pas d'accord avec ce mon
chchef sur ses temps je la ça se
papasse tous les jours.
- - Il y a quelque chose de sain
llà-d-dedans.
- - Tout à f fait incessants qus
dédéputés se donnent ce droit-l.
JeJe fais parti de ce groupe-là,
j'j'ai toujours confiance au
gogouvernement mais je ne suis s
d'd'accord les éditions la.
- - Je ne suis pas sûr r que cee
vovous dîtetes, que les maisonst
s's'atténuer se réalisent. Moi e
pepense que c'est profondément
inincrusté. On a parlé moment
dodonné d'un passeport Center qi
titiendrait compte de la troisie
dodose. Ce n'est pas de naissane
dede l'abolition des mesures
sasanitaires.
- - Les risques à r raison préf.
- - Dans le Journal de Montréal,
onon faisait zéro Dr Carmant Wes
quque...
- - on va vous laisser atterrir,
vovous réhabituez au masque.
- - Patrice quand je suis partin
nonovembre, on est demandé pas e
papasseport médecin il est
dedemand